[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié aux idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
27 avril la fête des fleurs et des
jardins de retour à montigny le
bretonneux 15e édition de la prairial ce
week end rendez vous incontournable des
amoureux du jardinage et de la nature
nous recevrons alain aubriet commissaire
général de l'après rial et membre du
lion's club du saut à l'élastique
inversée et un parcours d'airsoft pour
la belle saison lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines s'offre deux
nouveautés les activités à découvrir
pour les amateurs de sensations fortes
devenez architecte à rambouillet au
palais du roi de rome les enfants pour
mission de répondre à une commande
construire un hôtel particulier
une exposition est consacrée à ces
demeures un peu spécial mélanie poker
nous en parlera dans notre rendez-vous
junior
les coureurs sont attendus dimanche 6
mai pour la 8e édition du trail des
lavoirs à chevreuse encore 200 places
restantes pour participer à cette course
en pleine nature au coeur de la vallée
de chevreuse départ donné à 9 heures au
château de la madeleine
deux parcours sont proposés 32 23 km
chaque année environ 1000 coureurs se
retrouvent sur la ligne de départ pour
s'inscrire rendez vous sur le site de
l'association de la route des quatre
châteaux 150 photographies pour explorer
la notion de territoire une exposition à
versailles nous emmène dans des paysages
épurés ou des univers urbain dix neuf
photographes de l'association versailles
images nous partagent leur vision du mot
territoire un voyage à vivre jusqu'au 31
mai au domaine de madame elisabeth
chaque auteur à son mur
et donc sur son mur peut aménager et
organiser la scénographie qu'il entend
parfois c'est un territoire plus tôt
descriptif
alors avec des qualités propres propres
à chaque auteur mais c'est plutôt
descriptif donc des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément une culture photographique
fortes vont se retrouver parce que voilà
il s'est mis une notion de territoire
qui connaissent parfois c'est un peu
plus compliqué on a aussi la une des
visions c'est la notion de tribus
amoureux de la nature et passionné de
jardinage au rendez vous ce week end à
montigny le bretonneux 15e édition de la
prairial à la ferme du manet bulbes à
fleurs arbustes mais aussi artisanat et
produits du terroir sont à retrouver
avec nous alain aubriet commissaire
général de cet événement est membre du
lion's club bonjour bonjour
alors cette année encore de nombreux
exposants sont attendus que pour
attendre on retrouve s mais comme
d'habitude on trouvera trois types de
d'exposants des d'abord le plus
important des exposants du jardin c'est
la fête des fleurs et des jardins c'est
le sous titre de l'après real donc on
peut acquérir cette période de début de
de plantation quérir des plants d arbres
beaucoup de choses et puis aussi de la
décoration de jardin voire de
l'aménagement de jardins
et puis au fil des années nous avons
développé deux autres activités une
concernant l'artisanat à condition que
ce soit l'artisanat orienté vers la
nature et un deuxième pôle qui est un
marché des saveurs
ce sont des produits non pas en grande
quantité c'est pas c'est pas une foire à
tout mais plutôt des producteurs
sélectionnés qui change tous les ans
certains sont fidèles aux très petits
producteurs français va s'associer à
voir mais il y en a qui viennent de nice
à cannes de niche avec anne de bretagne
un quine du nord c'est vraiment là
de 80 de la france et pour cette
quinzième édition vous accueillait de
nombreuses nouveautés également des
nouveaux exposants
alors on en a toujours renouvelé les
exposants souvent c'est et cette année
c'est pareil à peu près 50% de
nouveautés je peux pas tout dévoiler
parce que sinon normandie y est ce qui
va se dire ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
c'est que nous cherchons à favoriser les
jeunes pousses dans la nature c'est une
bonne chose mais aussi dans les
entreprises et certaines entreprises qui
sont des des des personnes qui sont en
train de se lancer
vienne et avec une participation modique
voire nul
on les invite pour qu'elle se fasse
connaître et quel est ton dos en termes
c'est leur première activité est là pour
la cette année on aura deux de
nouveautés que l'on pourra voir
l'insuline ce sera une activité qui
tournera autour des lapins et l'autre
une activité qui tournera autour de
l'élevage de poussins d'accord donc à
découvrir à ressemble à découvrir sur sa
lancée en tout cas qu'il ya peut-être
des poules dans leur jardin pourquoi pas
tous et c'est une mode actuellement il
ya beaucoup de gens qui se lance dans
cette activité en temps un autre temps
fort autre nouveauté justement un
concert sera organisé samedi soir alors
le conte l'histoire du concert c'est là
de deux ans nos amis de wicklow qui est
jouée chloé qui est la ville jumelle
avec contini le bretonneux ont entendu
parler de cette manifestation d'après
rial et surtout du fait que la prairie
elle sert à subventionner des chiens
guides d'aveuglés et cette idée leur a
énormément plu et ils sont ils nous ont
demandé de venir à montigny chanter pour
pouvoir donner des fonds
à cette cause c'est pas toujours facile
parce qu'il ya toujours des frais qui
sont inhérents à un déplacement d'un
grand groupe
mais il y à 40 c'est un choeur d'hommes
de 40 personnes c'est assez rare en
france on n'en voit pas beaucoup et pour
donner un petit peu d'animation le
la chorale des quatre-vents de montigny
va aussi y participer donc on aura un
spectacle le soir à 20 heures à la ferme
du manet une partie il met huis clos
mais le corps le la chorale de montigny
et puis à la fin un ensemble les deux et
donc l'entrée est libre mais on invitera
tous les spectateurs à passer devant et
chapeau parce que c'est cette
participation à qui permettra de
financer l'opération
et justement tous les bénéfices de cette
manifestation de l'après rial sont
reversés dans la lutte contre contre la
société jusque là il faut savoir que au
lion ce club on a deux deux activités on
à l'activité interne de toute
association avec je dirais neutre
notre fonctionnement et puis on a une
activité de créer des manifestations et
de faire vivre avec un compte
particulier et donc l'intégralité des
sommes que l'on touche à la cette
manifestation naturellement déduite des
quelques frais que que que nous avons
pour pour la manifestation soit un take
intégralement reversé faut savoir que la
forme et d'échangés dans la période nous
rapporte à peu près dix mille euros par
an en moyenne est donc un chien ça coûte
que coûte cher et l'idée c'est donc de
pouvoir tous les trois ans à peu près
financée et financier un chien guide
parce qu'on leur a pas vraiment car
voilà oui la liste d'attentes pour un
chien guide c'est à peu près deux ans et
il faut savoir qu'un chien coûte cher
puisque les siens restent la propriété
de l'école des chiens guides de paris
qui est une école qui a été fondée par
le lion's-club il ya déjà pas mal
d'années maintenant je crois que c'est
40 ans et donc 7
le chien est bien il est élevé il ya un
élevage qui est à buc
ensuite il les nourrit les éduquer il
est accompagné on la campagne dans sa
retraite
tous les frais vétérinaires et de
nourriture sont pris en compte
c'est ça que ça et ils sont
naturellement de offert gratuitement ou
non programmé ça
ça coûte au pouvoir financier du club
ont conclu en tout cas merci beaucoup
alain aubry est revenue sur notre
plateau jeux se conclure en précisant
que l'entrée est à 2 euros 50 mais
gratuite pour les mineures et elle
permet du coup devenir tout le week end
venez en profiter pour l'occasion en
tout cas de profiter des fleurs tout en
faisant une bonne action pour la lutte
contre la cécité merci beaucoup à l'art
brillait merci à vous
plus de 900 mille personnes ont visité
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines mantes 2017 pour rester dans
cette dynamique de nouvelles activités
sont proposées cette année le saut à
l'élastique inversée et le parcours
d'airsoft un reportage de nicolas
kirilow vip kirillovitch m à riantec
[Musique]
atteindre la cime des arbres en quelques
secondes
c'est désormais possible avec le benji
éjection bien harnachés au baudriller
les participants sont éjectés dans les
airs à l'aide de deux élastiques pour 8
euros sensations fortes garanties
on sent se sont propulsés vers le haut
nous a fait une sensation un peu comment
les parcs d'attractions quand on descend
mais là et on se fait propulser vers le
haut et quand on arrive au point
culminant et qu'on amorce la descente
voilà on a vraiment la sensation
similaire aux montagnes russes depuis
l'ouverture une soixantaine de curieux
se sont essayés au saut à l'élastique
inversée dans les airs toutes les
figures sont permises et si l'activité
en effraie plus d'un
tous sont satisfaits de sauter le pas
alors des ports il ya une certaine
appréhension surtout quand on regarde la
personne passait avant soit ensuite
quand se faire lyncher
c'est à dire un peu plus dur parce qu'on
est dans l'inconnu si la personne n'a
jamais fait et ensuite comme l'a dit
simon
quand vous y êtes vous avez pu le soin
l'animation vise un public large seules
contraintes pesant entre trente et cent
dix kilos et avoir minimum 6 ans au sud
de l'île dans l'esprit du jeu vidéo et
proposer une autre activité nouvelle
l'airsoft on a des obstacles avec des
cibles on les touche autant de fois
qu'on veut on a une centaine de billes
pour s'amuser le plus rapidement
possible donc
donc voilà avec heures avec les
répliques ça s'adresse à un public
plutôt large en général en revanche
pardon il faut avoir plus de 18 ans
voilà ça c'est la loi
on ne peut pas mettre de répliques dans
les mains d'une personne mineure
pour le moment seul un parcours existe
mais en deuxième est en cours de
création
celui-ci favorisera les jeux de rôles
pour apprécier à plusieurs cette
nouvelle activité de ville de loisirs
[Musique]
c'est la fin des vacances mais pas la
fin de notre rendez-vous junior mélanie
nous a rejoint en plateau cette semaine
vous nous proposez un atelier où les
enfants vous faire fonctionner leurs
mélanges et leur ment et ce rendez-vous
va peut-être faire naître des vocations
à rambouillet les enfants deviennent des
architectes dans une maison chic c'est
le nom de l'atelier nomade qui est
actuellement au palais du roi de rome
une exposition pensé autour de l'hôtel
particulier une grande maison qui se
développe à partir de la fin du 14e
siècle
les enfants reçoivent une commande donc
un commanditaire farfelu leur passent
commande et part de ses goûts de ses
désirs qu'il aime ce qu'il aime pas il
ya des contraintes de règlement
d'urbanisme qui sont donnés également et
les enfants à l'aide de très grands
modules en bois doivent construire un
hôtel particulier en tenant compte de la
commande savane donc de grandes maisons
imaginez qu'emilien l'hôtel particulier
pouvait accueillir trente habitants une
famille complète noté parents les
enfants les grands parents voire les
cousins germains et même les domestiques
alors pour ce jeu il y a huit comme
commanditaire je vous donne un exemple
on va parler de sir richard ii hazell
lutte alors c'est un banquier
collectionneurs de 25 ans et même s'il
est célibataire et sans enfant il doit
loger cousin est loin
et la famille de son secrétaire un
sculpteur et 21 domestique est
l'exposition se visite de deux manières
alors il y à la visite libre avec les
parents l'exposition prendra fin le 3
juin prochain
il reste donc un bon mois pour en
profiter mais si vous voulez aller un
peu plus loin il y a trois dates à
retenir en mai l'exposition elle elle
passe en mode ateliers les 6 13 et 27
mai prochain à 16h une visite qui est
animé par un grand conférant un guide
conférencier et les talents des
constructeurs des enfants sont attendus
les apprentis architectes ont donc
rendez-vous à rambouillet pour créer
leurs plus beaux hôtels particuliers
merci mélanie le 7-8 loisirs est
maintenant terminée on se retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
et d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
où
ouais
oh